black noir is the guy that all men want
to be
and all the ladies want to be with he's
an enigma
wrapped in a mystery wrapped in kevlar
and what
in what looks like a daft punk mask but
daft
punk he certainly is not and who the
character really is
is probably one of the most complex
mysteries at the core of the show
throughout this video we're going to be
breaking down the new theory that he
might in fact be either stan
edgar's son or his clone there will be
some spoilers here in regards to the
comics and show
so if you aren't fully caught up then i
highly recommend that you turn off now
make sure you smash that like button if
you enjoy the video and please subscribe
to the channel
if you think that i'm a hero just
kidding you guys are the real heroes
with that out of the way this is the
heavy spoilers show i'm your host paul
now let's get into the breakdown okay so
pretty much once a week we've dropped a
theory on who black noir really is
when you're wrong about something i
often find that the best tactic
is to throw as much ish at the wall as
possible and who knows
one of these might actually turn out to
be true right
we've jumped from it being a copy of
homelander to lenny
a clone of billy and even at one point
theorized it might be the offspring of
stan
edgar the latest episode of the boys
actually cast to the side a number of
these series
and we got a slight unmasking of the
character in the entry
under the cowl we could clearly see that
the character was
indeed black which completely wiped the
possibility of it being either a clone
of homelander
billy or his brother lenny in case you
don't know in the comic books
it was actually revealed that noir was a
copy of homelander
who throughout the series had been
committing horrendous acts whilst
dressed up as him
homelander obviously had no memory of
doing these and when he found out about
them
he slowly started to second-guess his
actions with it eventually leading to
him going insane
fooled by this homelander embraced the
darker side of his personality
and he became maniacal even attacking
the white house at one point
in order to overthrow the president this
is when the truth about noir was
revealed
and vogt had held him in the wings as a
contingency plan
in case homelander ever went too far
many people including myself
throughout the first season thought that
that might be the direction that the
show was going in
however as the series got more and more
popular
it became obvious that the twist would
end up out in the open before the series
actually wrapped up
so the creative team have clearly taken
inspiration from the work
but pushed things into a new direction
nathan mitchell
was cast in the role and though
initially it did seem like he was simply
going to be a stand-in until i locked a
big name down
it does seem like he will actually be
playing the character throughout
now when the second season first
launched there was this theory that the
entire time
noir wasn't actually just one character
but instead he was several
the clue was in the name black noir
which which just means black black
and it was thought that this could mean
there are actually two characters
named black and noir yes i'm not kidding
us fan theory guys we tend to go a bit
crazy sometimes
however that can now be cast to the side
i think as we do see in the latest entry
that noise flash looks like it's been
badly burned
and in the first episode of the season
this happened at the hands of the super
terrorist
so yeah we can pretty much confirm that
there isn't two versions of the
character
because of the reveal fans have started
to speculate that it could be connected
to stan edgar
aka the ceo of vogt now at the moment
there are really two mindsets in the fan
community that i've seen
the first one says that edgar is
actually noir
and after taking compound v himself he's
decided to don a mask in tight
in order to carry out certain acts under
the monika black noir
comic books are full of billionaire ceos
becoming mass vigilantes
but where this falls down is that edgar
was featured during noir's attack in
episode five
whilst this this could have been a
hologram i guess
maybe it does seem like he was the one
calling the shots from his office
so the theory it just becomes very
unlikely
edgar clearly has noi on a tight leash
as well
and it makes sense that he's not afraid
of homelander because he can call on him
if it comes down to it
but why does he trust noir and is there
something else going on here
well episode 7 could have given us some
clues due to its themes
if you checked out my breakdown of the
episode then you'll know i discussed how
this entry was very much about fathers
and sons
this was reflected in several of the
characters from billy and his dad
to lamplighter discussing his homeland
and ryan
vogelbaum and homelander and even
frenchie
dropped a couple of lines about his dad
at one point to kimiko
it got me thinking about the overall
arcs of the characters in the entry
and it is possible that this too has
been carried across to edgar
so with all this combined what if noir
is actually the character's son
edgar clearly has access to compound v
and
after seeing its work firsthand it is
possible that he decided to give it to
his own child
so that he could gain superhuman
abilities edgar would likely only trust
people close to him to carry out the
delicate matters that he has
and thus it does make sense that he
would choose someone to don the mantle
of noir
that was very close to him now on the
flip side of this
it also adds to why noir is so loyal to
edgar
carrying out all of his orders without
question the character
was likely programmed to be this way and
at this point
it does seem like he's more machine than
man however if edgar is actually his
father
it does make sense that he's trying to
live up to his expectations
hell most of the characters in the show
are just trying to impress their parents
and the only reason that annie and
lamplier ended up in the seven
was because one of their parental
figures guided them on this path
and by guided i of course mean force
them now this could be echoed with noir
who just wants to make his dad proud and
doesn't mind
ripping off someone's head to do it
along these lines
the other angle on this is that noir is
actually a clone of edgar
and many of the points that we've listed
would probably still remain
edgar likely trusts very few people and
you can't trust
anyone better than yourself unless
you're drunk of course
so it may be possible that he cloned
himself in order to have someone who
would be endlessly logged to him
giancarlo esposito is an incredible
actor
and pretty much everything he touches
turns into a phenomenon
he's the guy you call when you want a
big villain and i think it would be
great to see him
underneath the mask as the final reveal
if edgar is his father
he would likely know very personal
information about the character
including his not allergy which he could
have relayed to the seven
if he is his clone then it does make
sense that he would know this as well
or this could have been genetically
placed into the character
to give him a weakness to exploit in
case noir himself
ever went rogue and he had to be taken
down quickly either that
or all of these theories are completely
wrong and we'll be back with a
completely different one next week
now it could even be possible that noir
is actually dead at this point
the almond joy was stuffed into his
mouth and he didn't appear at the
hearing later
mae was also back with the seven and
surely he would likely inform vought
straight away of her betraying him
if he was conscious i hope that he's
just in a hospital bed or something
but for the moment his fate is a bit up
in the air
sending thoughts and prayers i guess he
just couldn't handle the nuts
what nuts these nuts although noir
isn't always in the limelight i love
that the character keeps popping up from
time to time
and every time he does i get chills he's
he's hilarious but
immensely immensely intimidating at the
same time
he can pretty much hold his own with
anyone and make you crap your pants
and if we're going off the comics he's
actually the big bad behind the entire
thing
i'm sure the show will keep us second
guessing right up until the end
and who knows maybe it's mother's milk
maybe it's frenchy
maybe maybe it's you it's you isn't it
i bloody knew it that's that's my video
next week sorted
now obviously i'd love to hear your
thoughts on who the villain really is
and if you enjoyed this video then
please drop a thumbs up make sure you
check out our breakdown of episode 7
which is gonna be linked at the end
we go over all the easter eggs and
things you missed so it's definitely
worth checking out after this
don't forget we're also giving away
three copies of the marvel phase one box
set
and all you have to do to be on the
chances of winning is like the video
make sure you subscribe with
notifications on and drop a comment
below
the winner is going to be chosen at
random on the 30th of october so make
sure you get involved
if you want to support the channel and
get to see content early then please
consider clicking the join button below
you can also come chat us on the discord
server linked in the description
or heavy spoilers on twitter thanks for
making it until the end of the video
you've been the best i've been paul i'll
see you next time
take care peace
[Music]
you